bonjour je m'appelle maxime bizarre j'ai
30 ans et je suis candidat pour être
votre prochain député je suis un enfant
du loiret où je suis né j'ai grandi et
je travaille la terre de notre
département celle du gâtinais de la
beauce et de la forêt d'orléans je la
connais cette terre comme agriculteur je
la cultivent pour vous nourrir
cette terre est aussi la source de mon
engagement
d'abord dans le syndicalisme agricole
puis comme élu local et à la tête de
l'office de tourisme du nord loire cette
expérience bénévole je souhaite la
valoriser et la mettre au profit d'une
espérance
l'espoir que vous serez entendu l'espoir
que les réussites souhaite encourager et
les injustices combattu l'espoir que nos
territoires ne soit plus abandonné
l'espoir que chacun soit respecté
notre responsabilité est immense ici
chez nous la résignation n'est pas une
option face aux crises sanitaires
économiques environnementales sociales
et identitaires mais nous ne pouvons
rester spectateur
j'appelle chacun à s'engager pour que la
voix du loiret résonne dans les couloirs
de l'assemblée nationale
fort du soutien de marianne dubois de
marc gaudet et des élus locaux j'irai à
votre rencontre dans chacune des 104
communes de notre territoire pendant ces
quatre mois à votre écoute nous
construirons des positions fermes sur
vos véritables problèmes et vos
aspirations
la santé le pouvoir d'achat la sécurité
des transports fort de ce mandat je
porterai votre voix je serai écouter et
vous serez entendu
ensemble nous allons bâtir un nouvel
espoir
[Musique]